well i want to talk about my favorite
number which is
and i have to look at my paper here 2
billion 147 million
483 and 647.
there's several things why it's nice
first of all it's a prime number and
everyone knows that prime numbers are
are the best numbers and it's just
not just any prime number it's a
mersenne prime number
not only is it a percent prime number
it's a double percent prime number
we only know four of them and this is
the biggest one
so okay this sounds like we're in number
five territory here
why is this computer file then well
there's two reasons
first there's a little reason um i do
computer security
and everyone knows that prime numbers
play a role
in in certain encryption schemes
and and other cryptographic protocols
but that's not what i'm talking about
today maybe next time we'll talk about
rsa where it's particularly relevant
but today the reason that this number is
relevant is
because it is the largest signed integer
this number has a binary representation
and i can write down the binary
representation
but i think it is actually enough if i
tell you the binary representation
it is one one one one one one
one one one i'm not gonna do all the
ones there's 31 of them
31 once and some of you might recognize
that it's very
close to a special number 32. um
so why why is this relevant a computer
doesn't understand
anything other than a zero or a one on
or off
so if you want to write down a number
like two or three or four
you're gonna have to represent it
differently using zeros and ones
now i'm sure that most viewers that have
watched other computer file videos
are aware of binary encoding
but we don't only want to encode numbers
this way we also have to encode the sign
half the numbers you want to encode will
be positive numbers or zero
and the other half will be negative
numbers
so what we do is we use the first bit to
say
whether it's negative or not so if it's
zero it's a
positive number or zero if the first
bit is a one then we're talking about a
negative number
this number is going to be a lot more
relevant
about 18 years from now and i'll tell
you why
but first we have to talk about
something completely different
which is the way unix keeps track of
time unix changed the world
it changed the world initially to be
fair for computer scientists the unix
keeps track of time
by counting the number of seconds since
a special date
in history now it's not particularly
special it's not the moon landing or
anything like that
it's just one that was chosen because
it's easy it is
1970 the first of january and then
zero hours zero minutes zero seconds
uh utc so for time why do we need
signed integers though because time just
keeps going up and up and up right
that's right i just mentioned the moon
landing um and if you want to represent
the moon landing in your system
you're going to have to tell the
computer this is before 1970. so you're
going to have to use
a negative number and that's why they
use
signed integers if in 1972 when they
introduced
the the epoch they wanted to talk about
five years ago
you wanted to do plus two years whatever
that is in seconds
minus five years whatever that is in
seconds and get a valid time
so that's why they decided to use um
signed integers
the 1970 first of january is called the
unix epoch
so if you decide to represent time as an
signed 32-bit integer
the biggest time in seconds you can
represent is
roughly 2 billion seconds if you
translate this into
years and months and days you know a
format that a human understands instead
of a computer the date you get
is the 19th of january 2038
at around 3 14 a.m and eight seconds
so pi pi o'clock it is actually quite
close to 5 o'clock i didn't
i didn't i didn't see that
there's nothing deep there going on i'm
pretty sure um
but you never know um so at that time
what will happen to any system that is
using this way to represent time
is that one second later the bit will go
from the maximum unsigned integer so in
other words
from 31 ones and one zero in front it
will add a one
and those of you that have watched the
video about two's complement
will know that the next number will be
one followed by 31 0's
which means minus the biggest number
in other words it means approximately
minus 2 billion seconds
starting from 1970. if we go roughly 2
billion seconds before
epoch we will go to friday the 13th
december 1901 so that means that any
device
which is keeping track of time in that
way will get
really confused and we basically get the
millennium bug
all over again there must be a way of
fixing this are people working on it
already
yes there are people working on it for
those of you old enough to remember
actively the millennium bug there was a
lot of hype surrounding it
and in the end no systems crashed but
that doesn't mean the problem wasn't
real
there were a lot of people that worked
hard and fixed the bugs
and fortunately they managed to catch
nearly all of them
the same thing will happen with the unix
epoch all the systems that are running
on 32-bit integers will be patched and
the solution is kind of obvious
we need to use bigger numbers um so the
obvious switch
is to use 64-bit numbers
okay and most systems these days are
64-bit right or new ones that are coming
out
yeah but even 32-bit systems can
understand
364-bit integers you just need to use
some tricks to do it
so it's not a limitation of the system
it was just
done back in the day because memory was
a lot more expensive back then
than it was now computations were a lot
more expensive um so they didn't want to
use
any more bits than strictly necessary
and nowadays we're swimming in bits
so 64. um you know it may sound like 64.
why did we only double it why didn't we
take more
well 64 bits actually gives you
quite a bit of extra time to work on the
next millennium problem
you want to take a guess how long it
takes
before we run out of 64 bits well i i
sense the trap is it's easy to think
you're just doubling the number but
actually
it's kind of like some kind of
exponential yes yes
you've avoided the trick um i will tell
you
when we will run out of 64-bit unsigned
integers
it will happen on the 4th of december
around 3 30 p.m eight seconds past that
in the year 29 22
77 026596
so i think most systems will will be
patched by the time
that this comes around believe it or not
that now magically gets rid of the two
zeros problem
just by shifting the range and if you
like this is the um
fundamental piece of magic which i think
we can do over here
just consider zero zero zero zero
plus zero i'm now